la crise de l'énergie pardon ce n'est
pas l'ukraine c'est le fait que depuis
maintenant dix ans on a décidé de ne
plus entretenir nos centrales nucléaires
vous rendez compte qu'il ya encore une
dizaine d'années et même moins nous
étions indépendants au plan énergétique
produit pas de gaz non mais nous
vendions même notre électricité nous
vendions entre électricité à l'europe
aujourd'hui on doit acheter donc la
guerre en ukraine est un sujet bien
entendu mais ce n'est pas le sujet
principal qui explique le fait que non
seulement vous allez payer plus sur
votre électricité mais qu'en plus vous
en vous n'aurez pas assez on va vous la
couper